a question that rarely leaves us alone
in love
is what exactly are other people's
relationships
like the question is far from
disinterested sociological curiosity
what we urgently seek to know is are
other people
in as much trouble as we are after a
furious row over nothing very much at 11
at night
or after yet another month that's
unfolded with almost no physical contact
we may wonder how statistically normal
our case might be
precisely because it threatens to feel
like a unique
curse most of us have a handful maybe
four or five relationships that we know
and keep in mind
are standards of what we understand by
normality
perhaps we met these couples at
university or they live on the street
and are at a comparable stage of life
without knowing that they are playing
this role these
sample couples function for us as a
secret spirit level
of love at tennis we might notice how
kind they are to one another
as well as how energetic and live they
remain
over dinner we might note how much
politeness they show to their respective
opinions
in the taxi on the way home we might
spot the tender way they hold each
other's hands
and naturally we might feel both highly
abnormal
and very wretched as a result but
our assessment of our love stories
suffers from a basic
and unfair asymmetry we know our own
relationships from the inside
but generally only encounter the
relationships of others
in heavily edited and sanitized form
from the outside we see other couples
chiefly in social situations where
politeness and cheeriness
are the rule we take on trust they're
blithe summaries of their lives
but we don't have access to footage from
the bedroom the uncut transcriptions of
their rows
or their raw nighttime streams of
consciousness
however we have all this and more about
ourselves
we can't help but be intently aware of
our own relationships
sorrows and absurdities the cold
silences
harsh criticisms furious outbursts
episodes of door slamming
simmering sexual disappointments and
times of aching loneliness in the
bedroom
because of this asymmetry quite
understandably we come to the conclusion
that our own relationships
are a great deal darker and far more
painful than is common
in times of distress we fling a
definitive accusation at our partner
no one else has to put up with this sort
of thing
we need to be fairer on ourselves and
our beloveds
to create space in our minds for the
scale
of our ignorance we simply don't know
we're lacking data we owe ourselves a
richer picture of love
than we have as yet secured this isn't
prying or cruel
we just need to better understand the
true nature of the task we're
undertaking
and the truth is that misery or at least
some kind of very serious longing and
scratchiness
is actually the rule far more than
public sources
ever admit it's not that we as a couple
are strangely awful or damned
it's that relationships themselves are
an essentially
an inescapably difficult project
part of the reason why we get it so
wrong is that we have the wrong
kind of art the movies we watch are
oddly coy
the novels don't tell it how it is it's
a marker of the problem that we almost
never leave a cinema
or close a novel thinking that is just
like
my life the dominant emotion of most
relationships is
ambivalence that is a complex mixture of
love and hate contentment and
confinement loyalty and betrayal
most loves are too good to leave yet too
compromised to generate
profound contentment they subsist in a
kind of gray zone
where moments of joy bleed into
stretches of melancholy
where at points we'll sob and a certain
the partner has ruined our lives
and then the following morning assisted
by a bit of sunshine and a brisk coffee
we recover a feeling that things are
basically fine
if we could properly see via tenderly
accurate films and novels
or chats in group therapy or with older
honest couples
the reality of pretty much any
relationship we might arrive at a
surprising
and deeply heartening conclusion that
our own relationship is in fact
two things above all very normal
and good enough
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book
calmly guides us with calm and charm
through the key
issues of relationships to ensure that
success in love
need not be a matter of good luck for
more
click the link now